okay so the purpose of this quick video
is to discuss the differences between
saturated versus unsaturated fats so
let's get started now before we get into
saturated and unsaturated fats we have
to lay some groundwork with some basic
information about carbon from the
periodic table I know the atomic number
of six means six protons but it also
means carbon has six electrons so if I
draw the six electrons you might know
that the first level of electrons can
carry two electrons and then the second
level of electrons must be the other
four so the two in the first level
before and the second level adds up to
carbons six electrons so right now you
might recognize that carbon is an
unstable atom and as a result it will
form covalent bonds with up to four
other atoms carbon is unique because it
will bond up to four times in order to
become stable that's one of its unique
characteristics here's an example of
carbon binding four times in order to
become stable the carbon in the middle
has bonded with four hydrogens to become
stable there's another example of carbon
binding four times you notice how there
are two carbons look at the carbon on
the left there are four dashes attached
to the carbon on the left there's also
four dashes attached to the carbon on
the right so these carbons are stable
and now here's a triple bond example
here notice how the carbon on the Left
has four dashes attached to it four buns
and the carbon on the right has four
dashes attached to it for a button so
this is one of the unique
characteristics of carbon and this is
going to be important in a few moments
when we get into the saturated and
unsaturated fats well if we just first
of all look at lipids to begin with
lipids are one of the four categories of
organic molecules carbon-based molecules
so carbohydrates you know potatoes are
high in starch
starch is a carbohydrate proteins you
know eggs are high in proteins that's
more another one of the categories of
organic molecules nucleic acids such as
DNA and RNA and lipids well we're going
to transition into the saturated and
unsaturated fats in a moment well
chemically lipids have two basic parts
to them they have a head molecule named
glycerol and just the head because it's
kind of at the top and dangling down
they have chains of fatty acids here's a
fatty acid chain right here notice how
it's a collection of carbon and hydrogen
this is why they're called hydrocarbons
these fatty acids are a chain of
hydrocarbons and there tend to be 1 2 3
fatty acids that will attach to that one
glycerol to make a lipid this is also
commonly called a a glycerin and lipids
are great because they store energy and
your cells can use this energy but when
we actually look at the difference
between saturated versus unsaturated
fatty acids saturated fatty acids notice
how it's a long-chain carbon - carbon -
carbon - carbon and there's a single
bond in between every carbon and the
reason it's called saturated because the
rest of the atoms involved are
hydrogen's
this chain of carbon is filled with or
saturated completely filled with and
saturated with hydrogen member carbon
bonds up to 4 times every single open
bond is occupied by a hydrogen and as a
result this fatty add the saturated
fatty acid chain is dense and compact
and therefore solid at room temperatures
such as butter that you see in the upper
right hand corner
these also tend to be the saturated
fatty acids also tend to be the fatty
acids that are from animals for instance
butter is made from cows milk
so here's a glycerol molecule with one
two three saturated fatty acids and in a
dehydration synthesis reaction water is
removed and all four bond together to
make a lipid in this case a lipid made
from saturated fatty acids well when we
look at a unsaturated fatty acid at
least one double bond in between two of
the carbons and because of that double
bond there's less space for hydrogen to
occupy if you wondering well why can't I
just put two hydrogen's right there in
red in those open gaps well remember
carbon bonds four times if I add those
two red hydrogen's that would be a fifth
bond onto those two carbons that have
the double bond so that doesn't fit it
doesn't work so carbon bonds four times
let me get rid of those two in red so
here is a unsaturated fat notice how
it's not is completely filled with
hydrogen you'll also notice that there's
a kink in it that double bond causes the
chain of carbon to kink and Bend a
little bit and this causes the
unsaturated fatty acids to be more
liquid at room temperature such as olive
oil and these tend to be the fatty acids
that come from plants and fish sets and
so here is a picture of a mono
unsaturated fatty acid mono as a prefix
that means one notice how there is one
double bond in this unsaturated fatty
acid this is why I thought in mono
unsaturated fatty acid
well here's a picture of a
polyunsaturated fatty acid that just
implies that there are multiple double
bonds located throughout the fatty acid
chains and so there you have it a quick
side-by-side comparison of saturated
versus unsaturated fatty acids I hope
you found this video to be helpful and
please leave your comments in the
comment box below thank you for watching